SIERRA: They say you can’t pick your family
or your coworkers.
The same goes for global relations.
To quote a tweet once posted by my boss Richard
Haass “You have to deal with the leaders
that exist, not the ones you prefer.”
The United States likes to think of itself
as upholding values - including those of democracy,
freedom, and human rights.
But maintaining global partnerships often
means dealing with those you may not choose
to call your allies.
Administrations often have to balance values
with interests, which can involve troubling
compromises.
Such is the case in our relationship with
Saudi Arabia.
For starters, they have a lot of oil, which
helps them to dominate the global market and
control what we pay at the pump.
And it gets a lot more complicated.
I’m Gabrielle Sierra and this is Why It
Matters.
Today, the US-Saudi relationship, what is
it built on, what it looks like, and what
is happening within the country that makes
this partnership controversial?
Gabrielle SIERRA: So what is Saudi Arabia's
role in the world of energy?
Steven COOK: I think the word that first comes
to mind when someone says Saudi Arabia is
oil and that's because Saudi Arabia is among,
if not the most important, oil producer in
the world.
SIERRA: This is Steven Cook.
He is a senior fellow for Middle East and
Africa studies here at the Council on Foreign
Relations.
COOK: It can produce a lot of oil at a relatively
low cost, and it can do that relatively quickly.
SIERRA: How much of our energy supply in the
US comes from Saudi oil?
COOK: It's actually not as much as many people
think.
And the fact of the matter is that in terms
of crude oil imports, Saudi Arabia supply
6% of the American supply.
SIERRA: Wait, hold the phone, just 6 percent?
COOK: About 500,000 barrels of oil for the
United States on a daily basis.
This trails well behind Canada, Mexico.
SIERRA: Oh.
COOK: Canada's by far the biggest supplier
of oil to the United States.
Of course the United States is the world's
leading producer of oil.
The United States produces somewhere in the
neighborhood of 18 and a half million barrels
a day, but it also consumes 21 and a half
million barrels a day.
That's why it is so important in thinking
about a global oil market.
What are markets made of?
At the very basics, your economics 101, supply
and demand.
So when the market is out of balance, Saudi
Arabia is also often looked upon as what energy
analysts and others call the swing producer,
a country that can ramp up production relatively
quickly at a relatively inexpensive manner
to bring the oil market back into balance.
So, this gives you a sense that even though
Saudi Arabia is not hugely important to the
domestic oil market, because it's a global
market and as I said, because Saudi Arabia
is kind of the low cost producer of choice
and can kind of metaphorically turn the spigot
on and off, that's what makes it very, very
important.
SIERRA: Got it.
Right.
So it's less that we need their oil and more
that they're a huge influence in the global
oil market, and we depend on that.
COOK: Right.
SIERRA: Simply put, when Saudi Arabia decides
to release more oil to the market, gas prices
go down.
And that’s good for anyone who has to fill
up their car.
High gas prices are a lethal political issue
in the US, and for decades, they have been
a strong and predictable force in approval
polls.
This makes Saudi Arabia an important consideration
for U.S. policymakers.
SIERRA: How did this country become the world's
biggest oil powerhouse?
COOK: Well, it's easy enough to say.
Look, in 1933, standard oil of California
got a concession to prospect for oil in Saudi
Arabia.
In March, 1938, the Demam seven, well blew
and Saudi Arabia had a commercial amount of
oil as a result.
That's how it became.
Then it was just a year afterwards, a little
bit of year afterwards that the first commercial
exports of Saudi oil went on the market.
The king flipped the switch, and it filled
a tanker at Ras Tanura which is one of the
most important oil terminals in the Persian
Gulf and off it went.
And since then, they discovered the world's
largest single oil field, or believed to be
in the Eastern province of Saudi Arabia, the
Al-Ghawar Field.
That's really how it became this powerhouse.
It's been important to Western economic development
ever since.
SIERRA: But the relationship has other important
features.
While Saudi Arabia is providing oil, the United
States is providing weapons.
A lot of them.
From 2015-2019, around 74% of Saudi Arabia's
arms imports were from the United States.
In the fall of last year, the U.S. State Department
approved an arms sale to Saudi Arabia worth
$650 million.
And just this summer the US sold patriot missiles
to Saudi Arabia in a deal valued at over $3
billion.
COOK: It's big business.
People think in terms of Saudi Arabia and
oil, but also think in terms of Saudi Arabia
and Americans weapons manufacturers, that
employ lots of people in the Fort Worth area
or in South Carolina, in other places where,
California, where they manufacture particularly
airframes, the F16, the F15, precision guided
munitions, The Saudis are big purchasers of
those things.
SIERRA: But there are further significant
aspects to US-Saudi ties.
Saudi Arabia, historically, has also acted
as an important geopolitical ally.
Madawi AL-RASHEED: It's extremely important
to emphasize that the relationship started
in 1945, but it evolved over the last 70,
80 years and few other issues became important.
SIERRA: This is Madawi Al-Rasheed.
She is a visiting professor at the Middle
East Center at the London School of Economics.
AL-RASHEED: So for example, in the 1980s,
Saudi Arabia became extremely important for
the US, especially after the Iranian revolution
in 1979.
So the US was searching for another country
in the region in order to build its military
capabilities as a counter country to Iran,
especially after Iran adopted very hostile
rhetoric against the US.
And therefore, Saudi Arabia became drawn further
into the American regional hegemony, military
bases, armament, et cetera.
SIERRA: And it goes beyond this as well.
Experts say that it has also been in the U.S’s
interests to improve the Saudi relationship
with staunch US ally, Israel.
COOK: The Israeli Saudi relationship is, it's
an important reason this is something that
the United States has been driving for many,
many years.
It's actually not a function of any US effort.
Or maybe it's a function effect of what the
US is doing.
But that Israel and Saudi Arabia share a concern
over the exercise of Iranian power around
the region.
It's not just Iran's nuclear activities.
It's its proxies around the region, and the
fact that it funds Hezbollah, Houthis in Yemen
has supported, Bashar Al Assad in Syria lends
its support to Palestinian Islamic Jihad,
as well as hammas.
And so like in the the way in which Iran has
in part driven relations between Israel and
the UAE and Israel and Bahrain, it is also
playing a role in the far less open, but nevertheless,
clearly there relationship between Saudi Arabia
and Israel.
Now, also part of this is the fact that the
United States it neither is neither Israeli,
the Israeli government nor the Saudi government
agree with the American approach to Iran.
So, but nevertheless, the fact that the Saudis
and Israelis seem to have these under the
table relations, the US wants to encourage
them, because expanding what's called the
circle of peace is very, very important.
I think people believe that that would be
easier.
With good US Saudi relations, then the Saudis
and the United States, the Saudis and Americans
at odds with each other.
So it's that in addition to oil, obviously,
being, you know, first, among all other reasons
that the United States and Saudi the United
States wants to have good relations with Saudi
Arabia.
SIERRA: So there are multiple reasons that
each country needs each other.
And that motivates us both to maintain this
partnership.
COOK: Traditionally, it’s been, we have
provided security.
It's not written down anywhere, but we have
ensured the sea lanes and provide security
to the oil fields of the Gulf, and the Saudis
have worked to maintain a stable oil market.
So, you know, do we have leverage?
Do they have leverage?
Are we more important to them?
Are they more important to us?
SIERRA: Right?
I was going to say, who has the upper hand
here?
COOK: There's this codependency here.
SIERRA: Mm-hmm.
SIERRA: This unwritten contract between the
two countries is mutually beneficial.
The US offers a security umbrella of sorts
and secure transport, and Saudi Arabia in
return, maintains stability in oil markets.
It is a relationship based on two different
needs that must be met.
That’s sort of a simple set up.
But the problems come when you examine the
relationship with a wider lens and look at
some of the other actions Saudi Arabia has
taken over the years, and is still taking.
CGTN: The latest statement regarding what
happened to Jamal Kashoggi came from Istanbul’s
chief of prosecutor’s office, according
to this statement as soon as he entered the
Saudi consulate on October 2nd, was choked
to death and his body was dismembered and
disposed of…
CBC News: Today yet another airstrike killing
civilians was blamed on the Saudi led coalition
fighting Houthi rebels backed by Iran.
NBC News: So what we’re seeing in Saudi
Arabia at the moment is a brutal crackdown
on anyone who dares to criticize the government…
Peaceful activists, women’s rights activists,
political writers, bloggers…
they’ve been persecuted.
SIERRA: Saudi Arabia has done a lot of things
that violate international norms that the
US and other nations have signed on to uphold:
criminalization of dissent, execution for
nonviolent offenses, restrictions on free
expression, and airstrikes in Yemen that have
led to civilian casualties.
It’s no surprise then that over the years,
critics of American foreign policy have often
cited the Saudi relationship as problematic
and even a prime example of American hypocrisy.
SIERRA: So in recent years, what have been
the major points of disagreement or conflict
between the US and Saudi Arabia?
AL-RASHEED: In the US, there is a current
that questions the integrity of this relationship
between a country that claims to lead the
democratic world and a dictatorship like Saudi
Arabia.
Well, obviously, those people who know about
foreign relations, the US has maintained very
close contact with nasty dictators in South
America, in Latin America, in the Middle East.
SIERRA: As Madawi points out, our relationship
with Saudi Arabia is not unique.
We often have relationships with countries
and rulers that are counter to our values
in order to meet another need.
Critics have also questioned our relationship
with China for human rights violations and
Pakistan because of their shifting loyalties.
AL-RASHEED: And there is this current that
doesn't accept the fact that so-called democracy
like the US could have this intimate relationship
based on interests purely.
And this current got very stronger after 9/11.
Let's not forget that 15 of the hijackers
who hit the Twin Towers in New York were Saudi.
And therefore, many people in the US questioned
this relationship.
CBS News: Newly declassified documents show
links between the 9/11 hijackers and Saudi
nationals with connections to the Saudi government
CBS News: It was not possible for 19 men to
kill nearly 3,000 Americans that day without
a support network and a support structure
that helped them move seamlessly around the
United States for a nearly two year period.
AL-RASHEED: Saudi Arabia was also the homeland
of a very radical Wahhabi Islamic tradition
that inspired global jihad.
And therefore, people in the US always had
question mark about how close the US could
get to Saudi Arabia without jeopardizing its
own national interests.
COOK: What you're getting at is this question
that has bedeviled American policy makers
for a very, very long time, which is the United
States is supposed to stand for something
in the world, that American values are important
to Americans in the conduct of our politics
at home, but also abroad.
We don't always live up to those ideals and
values, but we like to think that we strive
towards them.
In the Middle East, we have never really done
that because our friends in the region don't
share our values and our ideals.
Yet, they are the people who sit a top lots
and lots of oil, which is important to the
functioning of the American economy and in
fact the global economy.
So we've been willing, and of course it makes
people uncomfortable, but we've been willing
to shunt aside those questions of human rights
and decency and tolerance because the Saudis
are among oil producers the most important,
arguably.
SIERRA: Okay, guess it’s time to take a
deeper dive into the inner workings of the
country and what life is like.
Just what sort of partner are we partnering
with?
SIERRA: So let's look inside Saudi Arabia.
So can you tell me some basics?
Who is the current leader?
COOK: The current leader is King Salman, who
is one of the remaining sons of the founder
of Saudi Arabia, King Abdulaziz.
He became the king and now he's the guy.
But he's quite old.
So the crown prince, his son Mohammed bin
Salman, is the guy who's been kind of running
day to day operations for Saudi Arabia.
It's almost as if King Salman is the chairman
and Mohammad bin Salman the crown prince is
the president and CEO of the company.
MBS was tapped to be basically the King's
wing man, right hand man, and ultimately his
successor.
AL-RASHEED: I think it's that intimate relationship
between father and son, and he appointed him
to so many positions.
So he is a Minister of Defense.
He's a crown prince.
He's the head of the investment fund.
He basically controls Saudi Arabia today.
It's a one-man show and it's Mohammed bin
Salman's show.
SIERRA: And Mohammed bin Salman, aka MBS,
has made sure to secure his place as the head
of the country.
In 2017, a group of wealthy Saudis, royals
and senior government officials were detained
by the Crown Prince in a hotel in an effort
to consolidate his power, an unprecedented
move.
Al Jazeera: Media reports suggest at least
20 princes, officials, and army officers have
been arrested in the kingdom’s latest purge;
the royals have been accused of plotting to
overthrow the crowned prince.
SIERRA: But not all of MBS’s actions have
been this forceful.
He has opened the country to more cultural
activities, he’s lessened the restrictive
power of religious leaders.
Women have been granted the ability to drive.
MBS has also launched Vision 2030, an ambitious
plan intended to reduce the country’s dependence
on oil, encourage massive private sector investments,
and focus on recreation and tourism.
ABC News: Historic change in Saudi Arabia,
women getting behind the wheel, driving on
the open road.
Engadget: In January of 2021, Saudi Arabia
announced plans for its own futuristic city
called, The Line.
CNBC: All the players in the LIV golf invitational
set to make huge money.
The tournament has already lured some of golf’s
biggest stars, Phil Mickelson, Dustin Johnson,
and Sergio García.
SIERRA: Is MBS popular in Saudi Arabia?
How much can we know about what, let's say,
regular Saudi citizens feel about him?
AL-RASHEED: In a dictatorship, you can't really
do opinion calls.
And therefore, it's very difficult to assess
the popularity of Mohammed bin Salman.
However, superficial observation would tell
us that, oh, when there is a concert or a
popstar visiting Saudi Arabia, Saudi youth
flood to the streets.
They chant, they dance and they are actually
enjoying the opening of Saudi Arabia under
Mohammed bin Salman.
COOK: He's been rather shrewd when it comes
to his domestic politics.
And his top down authoritarian reforms have
proven to be quite popular and in many ways,
revolutionary.
Look, the sweet spot for him are Saudis who
are aged 18 to 50, that's the vast majority
of Saudis.
So the very fact that young Saudis can go
to concerts, and raves, and the movies, and
young Saudi men and women who are not married
can sit at a restaurant together, and flirt,
and do all things that they were never able
to do publicly before, has created what seems
to be a reservoir of support for MBS.
At the same time, he's built a national security
state that...
Saudi Arabia is obviously never democracy,
obviously the royal family has established
a means of political control, but there's
been a real increase in the surveillance of
Saudi's society since MBS emerged.
SIERRA: But it feels very much like, "I'm
giving you those things, no one else is giving
you those things."
Like I know with the women driving, it's like,
"I did this," and that's the news we hear.
But we don't hear the other side where activists
were getting arrested, people who pushed for
this.
COOK: That's right.
And so, reform can't come from below, it has
to come from MBS.
And anybody who then takes his reforms, his
moves and then wants to run with it, push
it further, are in very serious jeopardy.
SIERRA: Many women activists in particular
have faced this jeopardy first hand, especially
those who advocate against male guardianship
- it’s a system that remains in place in
Saudi, and gives male family members legal
control over a female family member’s life.
To hear one of these stories we reached out
to Lina Alhathloul.
She is the head of monitoring and communications
at ALQST, a grassroots Saudi NGO.
She told us about her sister, Loujain.
CBS Evening News: …Loujain Alhathoul dared
to take the wheel in Saudi Arabia when it
was banned by the conservative Islamic kingdom.
Al Jazeera: After 73 days in jail, she’d
become the face of a movement.
DW News: She campaigned for the right of women
to drive.
Lina ALHATHOUL: So my sister Loujain is Saudi
human rights activist, more focused on women's
rights.
She first started when she was in Canada,
approximately in 2013.
And once she finished her studies, she went
to Saudi Arabia.
And the first day she landed, she actually
drove from the airport to our house, with
my father filming her, saying that with his
name, that this is his daughter, that he's
proud of her.
And it went viral.
And this is how the campaign for the women
to drive really began.
And she was leading it.
SIERRA: Over the years Loujain continued to
speak out for women’s rights and against
male guardianship.
And even though some of these rights like
women driving, did come to fruition, at times
she faced harsh punishment for it - she was
once blindfolded and briefly detained, and
she served time in prison.
But Loujain continued her advocacy work, even
though she knew the threats to her safety
were growing.
ALHATHOUL: They broke into our house in 2018,
they took Loujain.
They didn't tell my parents where they were
taking her.
My sister disappeared for almost a month.
The official media was saying that she's a
traitor, that she betrayed the nation and
that she should be condemned to the maximum,
which is in Saudi, death penalty.
And of course we were terrified.
We had no idea what was going on, it was unprecedented,
this defamation campaign.
My parents were allowed to see her three or
four months later.
And it's always very difficult for me to speak
about this part.
So they saw a very weakened, fragile Loujain.
She looked terrified.
And she refused to say anything at that time.
And then came the murder of Khashoggi and
reports of torture in unofficial detention
facilities came out, before Loujain talked
even.
So when my parents saw her the next time,
they asked her about the torture.
And that's when Loujain told them that the
months that she was held in these unofficial
detention facilities, it was basically torture
facilities.
And that she was electrocuted, water boarded,
flogged, beat, and sexually harassed.
And she had the courage to say that one of
the men, she recognized one of the men who
was Khatani, and who was MBS's right hand
man.
And so after that, the trial began and the
charges explicitly mentioned her activism.
And if MBS sees you as a threat, he will imprison
you and charge you with anything.
So my sister, after that, she was sentenced
to five years in prison with a three year
probation.
So she went out earlier.
And she has a five year travel ban.
So I don't know how we can still believe empowerment
of women.
You cannot impose change on women.
You cannot silence them and tell them not
to ask for their rights and just impose anything
you want and say, this is what empowerment
looks like.
The process of women empowerment has to include
women.
Otherwise, it's not empowerment, it's another
kind of repression.
SIERRA: Lina has not seen her family since
this incident, and they are all on an unofficial
travel ban.
And she and her sister is not alone in her
experience.
Recently, a woman named Salma al-Shehab was
sentenced to up to 34 years in prison based
on posts she shared on Twitter.
SIERRA: What's the cost of our close dependent
relationship with Saudi Arabia, and I mean
cost in the widest sense.
COOK: There's certainly a moral cost.
I think that's the biggest cost is that anytime
an American president would talk about human
rights and values and tolerance, especially
when it came to the Middle East, Saudi Arabia
was the exception.
There's always been this Saudi exception and
that's because of its role in the global oil
markets.
What we've seen with president Biden, who
has sought to inject American values into
his foreign policy, is that he has had to
renege because of his parochial political
concerns with his poll numbers, which are
affected by high gas prices, as well as the
fact that there are kind of geo strategic
concerns in the Middle East.
It's uncomfortable and it actually causes
some outrage among people in the Middle East
who want to live in more open and democratic
societies because it's entirely obvious that
despite whatever public pronouncements an
American president might make about values.Our
conduct in that part of the world contradicts
those values and ideals.
SIERRA: Essentially, these are the conditions
we accept when we accept a relationship with
Saudi Arabia.
But does it have to be this way?
SIERRA: Do you think there could have been
a preferable Saudi Arabia under another potential
ruler?
AL-RASHEED: In my view, Saudi Arabia will
be a better country if there is serious political
reform, and Saudi Arabia moves into a kind
of institutional state and a constitutional
state.
It's very difficult to see that a change of
prince will actually make a big difference.
Saudi Arabia is an absolute monarchy with
no representation, no participation, no elected
parliament, no elected government.
And in my view, there is no super prince who
could actually change the situation.
SIERRA: I was going to say, I mean, do you
think it's possible for Saudi to transition
to a constitutional state in our lifetimes?
Is there support for that in the country?
AL-RASHEED: Well, that depends on several
factors.
First of all, you need a society that is actually
fed up with the lack of rule of law, the long
prison sentences, the lack of freedom of speech.
So if there is no bottom-up pressure on the
monarchy, I don't see any change.
The other thing is we need a kind of different
ruler, a different monarch who would be able
to listen.
But I don't see Mohammed bin Salman as listening
to anything.
And third, we need an international community
ready to support the drive to democracy in
Saudi Arabia.
This, I don't see happening in the US again,
or the Western allies of Saudi Arabia.
I don't see that they are pushing for any
kind of democratic steps, regardless of how
small they are.
I think simply they prefer to deal with this
close circle of princes.
But I think there is a lesson to be learned.
A close Saudi Arabia and undemocratic Saudi
Arabia is very dangerous, not only to Saudis,
but also to the international community.
Let's not forget that an absolute monarchy
under its nose, a Jihadi trend flourished,
and then it became global and the damage was
actually all over the world.
So a democratic Saudi Arabia would be beneficial
for not only Saudis, but also the international
community.
SIERRA: This is where the big question comes
- does Saudi Arabia matter so much to the
United States that we are willing to continue
the partnership?
SIERRA: Is this as good as it gets?
Because a lot of people feel like this is
a very toxic relationship.
COOK: It's a difficult and fraught relationship.
It has grown more difficult in recent years
because of changes in the United States, changes
in Saudi Arabia and changes in the global
political order.
Does the United States want to remain as invested
in the Middle East?
If that's the case, then if you look around
the region, Saudi Arabia is very important
to the region and to the global economy, and
that requires the United States come to some
sort of accommodation with it.
Can we step back from the region yet still
get the things that we want including the
free flow of energy resources?
Can we pivot to Asia?
These are all questions that I think we are
working out here in the United States.
Some people suggest that maybe the United
States can step back from the region that
these actors can actually be more responsible.
As far as internally, MBS is toxic.
You know, I mean, MBS, his human rights record
is not good.
How do you weigh that against large numbers
of Saudis, particularly young Saudis, that
sweet spot of 18 to 50 year olds who seem
to be very supportive of the reforms, not
liberalization that he has undertaken from
the top down?
How do you weigh that and say, "This is the
best Saudi Arabia we're going to have, or
this is the worst."?
In conversation with policy makers here in
Washington, if you strip away a lot of this
stuff, what Mohammed bin Salman has done is
he has defanged the religious police.
He has spoken out against extremism.
He has allowed women to drive, a Washington
holy of holy and he's interested in normalizing
relations with Israel.
Those are all things that the United States
has really wanted from Saudi Arabia for a
long time, but it also comes with this toxic,
this leader who is seeking to establish and
consolidate his rule using very, very nasty
methods.
SIERRA: So what can we do?
COOK: There are three options for the relationship.
The first is to allow the two countries to
essentially go their own way and not resolve
underlying problems.
The second is a realist rapprochement, where
we recognize the problems but the countries
are too important to each other that we agreed
to move forward despite the underlying tension
in the relationship.
And the third is a strategic compact, where
US and Saudi officials try to deal with all
of the underlying tensions, tensions between
the two governments and forge a way forward
for the future.
Those are three ways.
Admittedly, the last one is a tall order.
And because it does require both governments
to do things that they haven't necessarily,
at least up until this point, haven't been
wanting to do.
And so there's a sense that perhaps the best
we're going to do is that realistic approach,
which which leads to this kind of very interesting
question, you know, where can you draw the
line?
If you look at that history of the US Saudi
relationship, we've never been, we've never
been willing to draw the line.
And they've never been willing to draw the
line.
I mean, there were there were crises.
But when it's come to, you know, Saudi human
rights violations, or its dalliance, Russia,
currently, the United States government has
preferred to seek ways either to ignore those
issues, or to work with with the Saudis so
that we never really actually have to draw
a line.
AL-RASHEED: I do not want the US to boycott
Saudi Arabia, and I don't want the US to sanction
Saudi Arabia.
I want the US to make its help to Saudi Arabia
conditional on Saudi Arabia abiding by international
law, by international norms, and make the
US support conditional on Saudi Arabia behaving
as a respectable member of the international
community rather than a pariah that could
dare to send a death squad to kill journalists
abroad or spy on young Saudis in the US.
And therefore, US help should actually be
linked to certain political reform in Saudi
Arabia, not simply allowing women to drive.
And then if there is a constituency in the
US that is concerned about this kind of dubious
relationship, they should ask for more openness
when we are talking here about arms deals,
when we are talking about intelligence sharing
and all those kind of things that make the
relationship transparent.
Obviously on the Saudi side, it's very difficult
to make it transparent because there are no
accountable institutions in Saudi Arabia.
As I said, it's a one man show.
But in the US, we can push and Americans should
push for a more transparent relationship with
Saudi Arabia simply because the US has the
institutions and the accountability.
And we don't want any secret relationships
between the two countries because only under
the secrecy that Mohammed bin Salman gets
away with murder.
SIERRA: What would be necessary to become
independent of Saudi Arabia?
COOK: If ever we could pursue a rational energy
policy where we focused on alternative energy
and fuel efficiency, we would perhaps not
be independent, but not be so vulnerable and
complicit with the Saudis and others, but
we haven't been willing to do it.
It's just easier rather than kind of pounding
away at energy efficiency and fighting with
the automobile companies and fighting with
your political opponents about it, or alternative
energy in which there is, you know, tremendous
culture war issues around that issue.
It's just easier to go to the Saudis and say,
Hey, you guys, can you pump some more oil
here and help us out?
SIERRA: Yeah.
COOK: It may make you feel uncomfortable,
but … yeah.
SIERRA
Right.
SIERRA: For resources used in this episode
and more information, visit CFR.org/whyitmatters
and take a look at the show notes.
If you ever have any questions or suggestions
or just want to chat, email us whyitmatters@cfr.org.
You can subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts,
Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your
audio.
If you have the time and love the show you
could leave us a review - it helps us get
noticed, we also just love to read them.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is produced by Asher Ross and me
Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Our intern this semester is Mormei Zanke.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Extra help for this episode was provided by
Rafaela Siewert and Claire Klobucista.
Our theme music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
We’d also like to thank Richard Haass, Jeff
Reinke and our co-creator Jeremy Sherlick.
For Why It Matters, this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you around!